c'est le monument le plus visité de
france et même d'europe et c'est aussi
le passage quasi obligé de tous les
touristes qui viennent à paris la tour
eiffel car c'est d'elle qu'il s'agit
reçoit chaque année près de 6 millions
de visiteurs est aujourd'hui parmi les
trente mille touristes qui ont
courageusement grimper les escaliers ou
qui ont plus classiquement emprunter les
ascenseurs la tour eiffel a attendu son
sens 50 millionième visiteur le compte à
rebours a débuté dès ce matin et
philippe panis et patrick goupillon ont
attendu et même guetter ce visiteur
historique qui va être particulièrement
choyés dans cette queue au pied du
pilier nord le sens 50 millionième
visiteur de la tour eiffel s'ignorant
corps mais dans les coulisses le
décompte se poursuit' comme au premier
jour de l'ouverture de la tour au public
le 15 mai 1889
depuis l'origine de la tour des
registres en effet tenu journellement de
l'entrée des visiteurs dans la tour et
depuis très peu de temps c'est relayé
par un système informatique qui va nous
donner le top
le top c'est à 17h52 re quand phare
bousculades et direction le quillier
nord oublié de se présenter de 58
visiteurs des dizaines de journalistes
de tous les pays au coude à coude
événement avec une chose qui est un
symbole surtout pour les étrangers nous
demandait américaine l'offre et faire le
procès c'est pareil c'est même la france
vous vouliez l'avoir la voici la chance
du jour se cache derrière d'élégantes
lunettes noires et les de carcassonne
mais travaille en région parisienne
gardienne de la paix elle gagne une
voiture mais a provisoirement d'autres
préoccupations vous avez perdu votre
famille près de six millions de
visiteurs en 1992 la tour eiffel
monument payant le plus visité de france
devrait accueillir son 200 millionième
client dans 7 8 ans lui aussi sera
couvert de cadeaux mais rassurez vous
ici il y a des souvenirs pour tout le
monde